I think one of the great things a lot of
the San Francisco's so from I just
wanted to Prague raphy offer you know
it's a great walk in turn you just you
can walk around San Francisco and
suddenly you know you get up in one of
the hills and you're looking over and
say hey and you just got a completely
different aspect you can't believe they
were you're you know you're just a
marriage Don to this disown you can just
see all over the place now you you dip
down into this and into this kind of get
kind of cool neighborhood you'll never
saw seen before I mean it's just done
and it's obviously because of its always
you know again it's chained me all
american cities are changing because of
maybe maybe San Francisco but I was
going to say that I fluences it's driven
out a lot of the edge to San Francisco
speaker ever used to go there and do
piece too and you know the the
economically disadvantaged oyster just
always to flock to San Francisco and
people used to go there for the vibe and
the other the whole canopy thing and
stuff like that and but um now it's you
know it's the recession might kind of it
ironically might restore became the
glory of San Francisco in a way you know
and stop it being this kind of yuppie
paradise which is going to just become
the whole silicon finger one
you